hello everyone and welcome back to the
very strong 1936 international
tournament in Moscow we have a game from
round 10 it's the last round before
everyone plays yet again against
everyone but only with colors reversed
as it is a double round-robin when do
white pieces it's a very strong
international Soviet select
international Nestor Ilya Abramovich
Khan vs. Jose grow Capablanca so it's a
kappa vs khan and cap i still in the
lead and if he manages to you know not
lose a single game and then he can go
into the second half of the tournament
still controlling controlling the
tournament it's a very interesting game
it was considered to be the the best
game of the tournament played so far but
you know we're gonna check out the other
half of the tournament as well maybe
there will be some other games that will
you know get this kind of credit and
it's also this game is mentioned in
garry kasparov
my great predecessors so it's it's
analyzed in length some four four pages
of analysis there as well so i've also
used a couple of some of the comments
from there but also some of the comments
will be from capablanca himself now as a
couple of previous four challenges were
a bit difficult here is an easy one just
you know ease into the new week so here
it is who is this gentleman for for one
point and for some extra points
what is he most known for best of luck
to everyone now let's check out the game
Ilya Bromwich count goes be four we have
E 5 9th to c3 going for the Vienna game
and the Capablanca goes for Bishop to c5
here kappa blanka says that in those
days the usual line was Knight f6
followed by f4 but then you kind of have
to go into d5 the main line of the
Vienna and the capablanca I didn't want
to go into this
he played Bishop to c5 the so called
Anderson defense and here we have nice
to f3 and the Coppa says that by playing
Knight to f3 it was already clear that
he that Khan was not interested in going
for a full point or whether he would be
satisfied with a draw because
if he wanted to play a sharp line he
would go f4 and after d6 I only then
develop the night transposing into the
classical variation of the King's gambit
but okay after Bishop c5 Knight to f3
we have d6 and now Knight to a4
immediately going after cup 1 because
Bishop as he did lock it in with this d6
move so okay couple monk will now lose
the bishop pair Bishop to b6 and the
Knight captures a capture some b6 and
now d4 it's very interesting already con
1 the bishop repair but he did give
capablanca the same you open a file and
he did well it seems like the pawn
structure is ruined but the pawn did
capture towards the center so it kind of
did even improved the pawn structure is
now the rook has a semi-open file and
you know that kind is kind of neglecting
his development as he already played as
removes with the night just just to get
rid of it but okay he captures on d4 and
now Queen captures on d4 here Queen to
e7 might be might be a bit better you
know just developing not allowing white
such a nice score for the Queen but
capablanca does that with the you know
here purpose of exchanging Queens with
Queen to f6
we have Bishop to g5 and there was a
well known game from nineteen eight from
1911 between schlechte Indian offski
where Bishop to d3 was played and the
game had you know resulted in in early
equality but here Bishop to g5 by Khan
we have Queen captures on d4 Knight
captures on d4 and Bishop to d7 now
brush up to C 493 7 castles and now nice
the g6 Capablanca doesn't Castle just
yet first Knight to g6 it's the idea
behind 90 g6 is preventing f4
because now if white plays f4 then h6
the bishop has nowhere to go because
here the knight will capture and after
have 5 so if captures captures black
simply ignores him in 95 and now both
bishops are under attack and black wins
the game so just a nice in-between move
before castling
here we have a three castles and now
rook a to d 1 kappa blanka develops the
knight Knight to c6 and here there are a
lot of things you can do here you can
play C 3 simply add protection to the
knight on d4 and if capablanca captures
then you will improve your Center
Knights the b5 isn't all that great
ok you are attacking this pawn but
Knight C to e5 attacking the undefended
bishop on c4 and after Bishop moves then
you capture the night after Bishop
captures then you have rook to a5
attacking the bishop and after Bishop
moves you get Knight f3 check bishop
moves and the rook captures on g5 so
black really you know exchanges the
material and now capablanca would be
very happy to play this position against
Khan so here instead after this Knight
to c6 move Capablanca suggested that the
very well Baku peculiar-looking Bishop
to see one because it will immediately
prevent this entire idea that's it the
rook after it comes to a 5 will be
already attacking the bishop on g5 but
already but also after Bishop to c1 you
will be able to push B 3 and a 4
white would enjoy pushing B 3 but the
rook is constantly attacking this point
so rush up to c1 a very nice idea by
kappa blanka preparing the B 3 and a 4
but here Knight captures on c6 is played
by Khan Khan exchanges material but
again capablanca says this only improves
his pawn structure yet again capturing
towards the center Bushra back to d2
again kappa blanka says Bishop to c1
would have been better still with the
idea of playing b 3 and a 4 because now
we have looked to a for Bishop to d3
getting away from the rook and now
Knight to e5 attacking the bishop bishop
to c3 and although Capablanca is better
here there's a there's no way to
actually prove that he's better but
white still has the bishop repair and
after f6 and f3 you kind of don't want
to capture on d3 if you capture then
you're left with opposite colored
bishops and then kappa marcus says that
it would be very hard
for any sort of advantage here we have
rook to e8 and now rook to f2 and here
kappa blanka finds a different way to
seek advantage
Bishop to c8 again capturing on d3
yes you do you know read white of the
bishop pair but then opposite colored
bishops and not something you can push
bishop to see it preparing bishop to a6
to exchange a light square bishop for a
light square bishop and then it's a
night against the dark square bishop
capablanca can work with that
here bishop to f1 was played although
this bishop place exceeding a couple on
cases can be easily prevented with rook
to a1 now Bishop trace X will be met
with the simple b3 and the rook cannot
go back because of the bishop you lose
the exchange here but okay after here a
bishop to f1 was played now comes Bishop
286 Bishop captures rook captures and
now Bishop captures on e5 again
Capablanca says that there's no good
reason for this exchange okay you do go
into a rooks endgame but this only
improves Kappa Blancas pawn structure we
have looked to d3 c4 would have been
better kind of preventing Capablanca
from creating a store and storm on the
Queen side but okay b5 now not allowing
c4 anymore we have rook to d2 and now c5
came to f2 you have to bring your King
into the game rook to a for a very nice
idea preventing white from pushing f4
because then the e4 pawn would be weak
Kim to e3 and now comes King to f7 rook
back to the one Khan here doesn't
doesn't have a clear plan of what he
wants to do we have King to e6 and now
comes King to d2 again
just waiting to see what Capablanca will
do rook to b8 transferring drove to the
Queen side and preparing to put those
pawns roof to c3 we have a g5 now H 3
and H 5 here rook to h 1r up to d4 with
check and King back to e to the couple
one has idea was if you block here then
you get c4 you have to capture look
after captures captures now black black
really has a nice advantage here so
after work before we have King 2
- and the now comes rook to g8 again
preparing g4 rook to d3 here kappa
blanka avoids the trade of rooks as he
very much enjoys his active rook our as
White's rook on d3 isn't isn't all that
great
rook H back to d1 and now g4 h captors
on g4 h captors on g4 and King to e3
here a couple vodkas idea was that if
white wants to grab the hold of the open
H file to play G captures on f3 with the
idea of rope captors on g2 so you have
to capture with the pawn but then rook
to G to check King T 1 and then comes
before with with some nice activity for
black of course if you capture you get a
rope to a-1 checkmate so a very nice
position for black after H captures on
g4 King to e3 was played but now rook to
e8 and I again a very nice idea now
controlling the H file you don't really
care about F captures on g4 if this is
played then simply rook back here
attacking the pawn after King defends it
rook a faith after King moves look f4
now attacking the pawn and the Jeep on
this would be winning for black so after
Luke a trade rook to b3 attacking the b5
point but kappa blanka doesn't care
about the b5 point he plays rook to h2
attacking the g2 point we have looked to
d2 defending it and now rook rook to d4
again offering also the b5 point but not
really here rook to e2 was played if you
play rook captures here then you get C
capture some before and after King to F
to G captures on f3 King captures nf3
nc6 now and again with a winning
position for black this this weak bond
will be will be too much for white to
deal with so after loop to d4 of course
you don't want to capture this and allow
captures and capture some G - so first
rook to e2
still keeping control of the g2 bond we
have c6 and the now comes rook to c3 and
here Capablanca should have played h1
but this is move number 40 so Blanca
needs to make one more move before he
reaches time control and then
he will wait for for Kant to also make a
move but that move will be
you know the game will be adjourned then
and continue tomorrow
but here capablanca actually played the
g3 and here the after I can't I wrote
down a move and you know that that the
game will be continued tomorrow and
tomorrow when they arrived here to
continue their game capablanca suggested
that if Khan prepared f4 then again
kappa blanka offers a draw but if he
didn't then the game will continue
Capablanca saw that after f4 rope to h4
f captures rook captures King moves rook
F for check King captures rubgy for
check King f3 a rook captures Ani to
King captures rook captures and G to now
King f3 the rock is under attack and has
to move rook h2 and now King g3 once
again attacking the rook rook moves and
only now he captures on d6 King captures
and here with the material being
completely the same it would be an easy
draw but unfortunately for Khan he did
not he did not play f4 he played rock to
d3 and now the game has to continue here
kappa blanka continued rook to h1 we
have f4 now preparing f5 we have rook to
f1 cutting off the king from the g3 pawn
as g3 pawn is essential for capablanca
to win this game
f5 was Czech and now King to f6 we have
c3 forcing a trade of rooks rock across
skin captures and now d5 now the pawn
storm is being pushed b3 we have c4 this
comes with check B captures pawn
captures and King to e3 here rook to e1
and now it's it's very much obvious that
the Queen side pawns are much too weak
here King to f3 was played
now finally can can grab the g3 pawn
rook captures on a three team captures
and now Capablanca captures the c3 pawn
we have King to h4 and now rook to see
one couple Blanca is up upon and with
with an excellent position we have G for
now if if Khan could push g5 then then
maybe he could still hope for something
here but Capablanca doesn't allow it
rook to h1 check King g3 now comes d4
now with two two connected passed pawns
this is game over
rook to a2 we have d3 King G - and now
rook to e1 attacking the pawn king f2
was played but it doesn't matter even if
you play king of three at defending the
pond and f3 series coming in the game
king f2 was played and after rook
captures on e4 ilya Bromwich can
resigned the game also in in Casper's
book the the first volume micro of my
great predecessors it says that also
King f3 was played and only then can
resign in the game but on chess Gamescom
it says that after rookie for the game
was over so but it doesn't really matter
I guess so yeah that was the game round
10 of the very strong international
tournament in Moscow both 1936 11 which
converse was a row kappa blanka i do
hope you enjoyed it so very nice you
know a demonstration of how to play the
endgame and you know a lot of people
said that you know as I already
mentioned in the first video of this
series that kappa blanka won this
tournament add that it was definitely
due to Capablanca superior endgame
technique that he was able to win this
tournament
so once again i do hope you enjoyed it i
would like to thank Simon LeMay for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciated as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon hopefully with some other inter
interesting games and I hope you enjoyed
the soccer game yesterday I was really
intense and yeah I really thought that
that Croatia was you know are out of the
game but somehow they prevailed so bad
luck for Denmark but you know some
someone has to lose so yeah I think I'll
and I will see you soon